After unveiling an epic sizzle reel for Star
Wars: The Rise of Skywalker at this year's
D23 Expo, LucasFilm has released the video
to the masses.
The special look is all sorts of incredible,
mostly due to its final few seconds, which
gave us the first official look at dark Rey.
Dressed in a black hooded robe, Rey wields
a double-bladed red lightsaber, which she
flourishes downward to snap into a battle-ready
position.
Her skin appears far paler than normal, and
her eyes look sunken into her head.
Suffice it to say, this isn't the Rey we're
used to seeing.
But what's actually at play here?
Judging by the clothes Rey wears and the red
saber, one could argue that she has officially
turned to the dark side, joining Kylo Ren
and the First Order.
Study her face and her posture a bit more,
though, and you'll see some signs that suggest
dark Rey isn't the real Rey.
Dark Rey is stiff when she handles the double-bladed
saber, whereas normally, Rey is swift when
working with her weapons.
Additionally, dark Rey is practically emotionless,
her face barely moves a millimeter, which
isn't typical of Rey's usually hyper-emotive
mug.
So, what does it all mean?
Well, there are a few possibilities.
This dark Rey shown in the new footage from
The Rise of Skywalker could be a clone of
the regular Rey, one of several that were
created at the time of Rey's "birth."
Considering The Rise of Skywalker will feature
a brand-new iteration of Stormtroopers, the
red-armored Sith Troopers, some theorize that
dark Rey and the entire fleet of Sith Troopers
are Rey clones.
This could tie into The Last Jedi, during
which Rey entered a cave and saw dozens of
copies of herself.
The idea goes that these multiple Reys weren't
just visions, they're real, which would help
explain why the Star Wars saga hasn't yet
fully explained Rey's parentage.
Sure, Kylo Ren snapped at Rey and told her
that her parents were nobodies who sold her
for drinking money, but perhaps the First
Order edgelord made it up to upset her.
Maybe, just maybe, Rey doesn't have any parents
at all…because she's one of a whole bunch
of clones made for the purpose of fighting
in the galactic war.
Perhaps her "sisters" are all evil, while
Rey is the sole clone who malfunctioned and
joined the light side.
Or maybe she's not a clone.
Maybe she had a twin, with Rey's parents having
sold her sister immediately after their birth.
The abandoned twin might have grown vengeful
and turned to the dark side, and the evil
Rey we see could be that scorned sister.
Another theory is that dark Rey isn't real
in the slightest, and that what we're seeing
in the Rise of Skywalker clip is part of a
sort of dream sequence.
Just as Luke Skywalker saw himself as his
father, Darth Vader, while inside the Dagobah
cave in The Empire Strikes Back, Rey could
have a similar vision in The Rise of Skywalker,
facing her biggest fear in watching herself
turn to the dark side.
This could give her the push she needs to
continue fighting against the First Order
when the temptation to turn dark grows too
strong.
There are about a billion possible explanations
for what's going on here, and the same can
be said for what looks like an evil version
of C-3PO in the newly released Rise of Skywalker
footage.
The protocol droid, known for his etiquette
and intelligence, is seen here with glowing
red eyes.
That's the only physical attribute of his
to suggest that the upcoming film features
a dark C-3PO, and while we hate to make sweeping
generalizations in saying that every character
with red eyes is evil, there's evidence to
suggest that this could be the case here.
"Don't say things like that."
In February 2015, Marvel Comics rolled out
a new Darth Vader series, which revealed in
issue number three that the heavy-breathing
dark-sider had in his entourage droids that
have the same design as C-3PO and R2-D2.
There's 0-0-0, essentially an evil version
of C-3PO from a design perspective, and BT-1,
an assassin droid that recalls the design
of R2-D2.
These robots are battle droids designed to
kill, which is a far cry from how helpful
3P0 and R2 generally are.
Speculation has it that the red-eyed C-3PO
shown in the Rise of Skywalker footage could
actually be 0-0-0, and that the Skywalker
who rises in the new movie is Anakin, who
may return as a Force ghost with his literal
killing machines in tow.
Since additional footage from The Rise of
Skywalker shown at a Disney shareholders'
meeting in March 2019 reportedly featured
Kylo Ren opening a container that holds Darth
Vader's helmet, it's not completely out of
the realm of possibility that the villain
formerly known as Anakin Skywalker could play
a part in the upcoming film.
On the other hand, maybe the explanation for
the "evil" C-3PO is simple.
Perhaps the reason why the droid has red eyes
during that scene is because he had his personality
inadvertently augmented to be extra aggressive
for the sake of comedy, sort of like what
happens with Data's "emotion chip" in Star
Trek.
"Yes, I hate this"
All this is to say that many mysteries still
surround The Rise of Skywalker, and hardly
any concrete answers are on hand right now.
Writer and director J.J. Abrams could have
taken the film in any number of different
directions, making it all the more difficult
to pin down which theories could be true and
which are total BS.
The Rise of Skywalker will surely answer the
big questions about dark Rey and the potentially
dark C-3PO, but fans will have to be content
with waiting until the film's release on December
20 to learn the truth.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
films are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.